Don, I want to start off by thanking you
for taking the time to be with us today.
I know the students are going to learn
an awful lot by hearing from you,
and I know you're very busy so
I really appreciate it.
>> My pleasure.
I wish we could share a glass
of wine at the same time, but
anyway, we'll proceed.
>> Well if we can figure
out how to do that you and
I will probably get very rich.
>> Well, we've got a lot of wine
up here in Charlotteville, so
I always try to help the locals.
>> Yes you do.
So, Don you've been a thought
leader in informatics for years.
You've chaired most of the important
IOM Reports that I've alluded to
throughout the course, so
you have a unique perspective.
Where do you think we are today on
transforming our health care system,
particularly through
the use of health IT?
And what are your hopes for the future?
>> Well, it's really been exciting
to have been involved in this.
I guess the only thing that's
frustrating is that I'm
not getting younger because I
think it still has to play out.
But we are really I think
making terrific progress.
When you consider that the 1991 report
on a computer based patient record
was called an essential technology for
health care and that it took
until just 2009 for
the high tech legislation to really
make this a national kind of development
with meaningful use and so forth.
So clearly, these have been
really momentous times, and
it's exciting to me to see that we
are way past the early majority.
We're into the late majority
of people now doing this
both in hospitals and practices.
So having said that, I don't know if
you saw, I can send you the reference.
But I had a paper with a couple
colleagues this years.
The way it was finally broken,
where are we now,
that spoke to some of the issues.
And there are a lot of issues out there.
There's not the interoperability
that we need.
There's not the functionality that
we need from the point of view of
even physicians, let alone all
the other members of the health team.
So it's a glass half full,
half empty kind of thing.
But actually I think it's
really in a good spot.
Some of where we are though is,
of course,
we mostly have been using health IT
in terms of say computer technology.
And I think increasingly now we're
using communications technology.
And all these things are new,
from the time the study was done and
it moved forward.
So, we're always going to be
in the situation of trying to
both keep up with where
the technology and opportunities go.
But a lot of progress has been made, and
I think what I'm excited about, to talk
about also, is where some of the pinch
points are and where we can go next.
>> Well, I will certainly post that
paper for the students to read.
As we look at a health care system that
is increasingly using digital records
instead of paper, the research community
is very excited about the prospect of
having access to huge amounts of digital
data to study it, to help improve care,
gain new knowledge, and maybe even
improve the healthcare system itself.
But I don't have to tell you, getting
to that data is often a very difficult,
time-consuming process, mostly because
of concerns about patient privacy.
Some people feel maybe the pendulum
has swung too far on that, and
we're actually harming our ability
to use digital data as a result.
What's your view?
>> Well, in fact, I am one of
those people who believe that.
Some of the issues are not necessarily
the HIPAA legislation per se.
But clearly I think HHS has not in fact
creatively tried to manage to this,
to balance these competitive goods.
Privacy's a good thing.
But too much privacy and
obviously you can't have knowledge,
you can't run a government,
you can't run research and so forth.
And I think that the principle problem
with HIPPA was that it was built in
an era, and it was all pre-Internet.
So the fact that you could
do data analytics and
do translational bioinfomatics and
the human genome and proteomics and
epigenetics with
epidemiologic data as well.
Let alone using it to improve health
care systems with clinical alerts and
even community health approaches using
public health dimensions to this.
All of that was well before HIPAA.
So, candidly, I've been spending
hours up on the hill with energy and
commerce staff to try to see if we can,
as part of their initiative
to improve, really cures is where
they're wanting to go, but care as well.
See how we can hopefully make some
reforms in these things because right
now it's not only a problem for research
it's also a problem for education too.
I hear issues where pharmacy
students are interested in trying
to learn how to do data mining and
looking at drug use and so
forth can't get to the record data at
some schools for some various reasons.
As I say, the issue is not only
the legislation which was built for
a different era.
Mostly clinical trials where
the patient was at risk, to secure use
of these data for data analytics where,
honestly, the risks are extremely small.
And I think, actually, if you look
at hospitals around the country
that are doing research, most patients
actually overwhelmly want doctors to do,
and other health professionals,
to do this research, and
in fact actually sort of assumed
that we already were doing it.
So, we really clearly
have some issues here.
And there've been cultural issues where
not all scientists have eagerly wanted
to share data, but I think the Clinical
Translational Science Awards have really
cracked into that.
Plus, what has happened in the last
100 years is the human species
has not only been very productive, but
they've been very reproductive too.
And as a result of that the human
genome's gotten more complicated.
So if we're going to
really crack these things,
which we can,
we really need very big data sets.
And you can't aggregate those, in fact,
where you talk to a group of patients or
patient advocates with one problem
because a lot of these
are multidimensional kinds of problems.
In fact most of them are.
They're not single, single chain or
single issue, single dimensional issues.
So anyway, tremendous opportunities, but
also candidly we are leaving a huge
amount of discovery on the table.
Example, another quick example, HIPPA
says you can use personal health data,
identifiable data for
doing quality studies in a hospital.
But if you find something that really
you'd like to share with your neighbors
and colleagues and publish it, you
gotta go all the way back to an IRB and
start all over.
Well, busy people may not
want to mess with that now, and
some big institutions,
they spend a lot of money and
extra effort to help facilitate
people being able to deal with that.
But, we can't afford to lose that
wherever it is, smaller institutions or
larger institutions.
So, we've gotta work smarter.
We can't work harder.
I think the government's not going to
throw more money at health care.
That's, I think, becoming increasingly
relevant for both research as well.
So we've gotta get better data
liquidity, as the term is called, and
let it move around for
care, for research, and
then also ultimately then for
population health.
>> Well, you've mentioned
patients a number of times.
And I think most people would agree
that patients are the ultimate
decider when it comes to
the use of their data.
And a number of people have suggested
that patients create their own data
repositories that might be housed in a
PHR or some other tool specifically for
the purpose of mediating
the sharing of their data.
Do you think this is
an inevitable development?
Do you think it's a good
development if it happens?
Might that be the way to increase
the accessibility of clinical data for
research and other purposes?
>> Well, if it were the only
approach I'd be strongly against
it mostly because that we
know at least 25% of people
really don't care if their
data are used for anything.
But they don't want to be
bothered to be asked about it.
So anytime you're carving out
25% of the population, and
keep in mind the population
may be split differently.
For example, a number of years ago
Minnesota passed a law that said you
had to get people's permission to use
their data, and it turned out Rochester
was doing a lot of work also in breast
cancer, particularly in younger women.
Well, in Minnesota,
it was very disproportionately
young women who decided to opt
out of having their data shared.
Well as a result of that
nobody could do research because their
sample sizes weren't big enough.
And obviously I think
that's the challenge.
It sounds kind of good from
a patient autonomy point of view.
But I don't think it's any way to get
discovery in an era where big data
where you really can try to get to the
core of things and create real cures.
Now, if you're talking
about certain areas,
I'm not saying that it's
a uniformly bad idea, but
if you only had one arrow you could
shoot, frankly I think we need to decide
that as a society, we care enough about
each other that we're going to share
our data to cure things so all of us
can live longer and live better lives.
And also, by the way,
have a cheaper health care system,
which we clearly need as well.
So, I don't know if that's responsive,
but that's a quick answer.
>> No, that's a great answer.
Well, Don, I think the students have
really gotten some tremendous insights
here from someone who's been obviously
one of the great thinkers about this for
many decades now, and I appreciate you
sharing those insights with the students
and taking the time with us.
Thank you very much.
>> Well you're very gracious.
I enjoy when we can get together and
obviously hope that it can
happen more often in the future.
If a particular student does have
a question that they'd care to
write to me about, I'm not saying how
quickly I'd get back to them, but
detmer@virginia.edu and
I'd try to respond.
And I'll also send a few references to
you that might be potentially useful.
>> All right, well thank you very much.
>> Yeah, thank you.
Have a good day.